foreign
[Music]
do you find yourself with a high amount
of workloads that only keep growing and
don't quite know how to scale up the
number of certificates you can request
in a given time period keep watching to
learn how you can use CA pools from
Google's certificate Authority service
to increase your throughput without
having to change anything about your
client or even talk to anyone
when requesting certificates there is an
enforced limit on the number of requests
that can be sent this is expected but it
makes it difficult to scale up your
workloads to the QPS that you need to be
able to request certificates more often
typically scaling up is a complex
Engineering Process that can take months
or even years to complete with a larger
amount of workloads what are my
constraints do I need to do load
balancing do I need to change my client
to make this work do I even have the
resources and time to put towards this
and most of the services available today
offer a low limit of QPS as your
business and its workloads continue to
grow being prepared for the future and
proactive about scaling is of utmost
importance for the smoother Journey with
Google Cas load balancing doesn't have
to be a complex and time-consuming task
it is the service for scalable
certificate issuance
Cas allows you to increase the
throughput of your Cas using CA pools
Google built CA pools to do the load
balancing between Cas for you and due to
their only being a single issuance
endpoint per CA pool this operation has
no impact on your workloads and doesn't
require any changes on the client side
it enables you to achieve even higher
QPS seamlessly and without downtime you
don't even have to orchestrate the scale
up we'll do it for you
to increase your total effective QPS you
can increase the number of CAS in your
ca pool with multiple Cas in the pool
the ca pool is then able to increase the
total effect of QPS by Distributing the
incoming certificate requests across all
those enabled State Cas in the pool
when you've implemented CA pools you can
increase QPS in as little as five
minutes all you have to do is add a CA
to your pool
create a new ca Stage IT test it enable
it and you can easily double your QPS
almost instantly make sure you're in
your ca pool in the right location
before starting
to create a subordinate CA with the name
subordinate one in your ca pool you can
use this gcloud command
make sure you replace pool name with
your ca's pool name to create additional
Cas just change the name from sub 1 to
sub 2 Sub 3 and so on in each command
while the newly created Cas are in the
staged State you can create and test
certificates to make sure that
everything works as it should
once that's done you can enable the cas
so let's say you have a CA pool with one
CA in it with a QPS of 25 and you want
to increase the QPS of the ca pool to
100. you can create three more Cas in
that CA pool using this method
you can verify the health of your ca
pool by using Cloud monitoring to
monitor your ca pools load balancing
metrics such as the number of
certificates issued per CA in a given
time period ideally there should be
uniformity in the number of certificates
issued by each CA a few things to note
there is a QPS limit but you can apply
for more if needed and the scaling is
per region scaling not Global so this
won't load balance between regions if
you find yourself with a high amount of
workloads that you need to increase
without the complexities that come with
scaling and load balancing CA pools with
certificate Authority service might be
exactly what you need have you tried
using CA pools to increase throughput
let us know in the comments check out
the links in the description for more
information and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
thank you